good morning Hank it's Monday January
3rd 2011 happy 4 year YouTube verse riad
dressed up because you know it's our
special day so Hank in today's video I
thought I would answer some of Google
autocorrects common questions beginning
is booked okay let's start from the
bottom is bearshare safe no but neither
are icepick lobotomies which we don't
use anymore either
is Bob Harper gay by the way Bob Harper
is a guy on The Biggest Loser let me
answer your question with a question
Google if we spend as much time thinking
about quantum physics as we do thinking
about whether celebrities are gay do you
think we'd have a unified theory yet I
do is Bam Margera still married yes
technically although he and his wife
live in different cities is Beyonce
pregnant 2010 no is Brett Farve married
yes is Bees it a scam no it's just a
ripoff is Beyonce pregnant still no is
bronchitis contagious yes is bleach over
no and lastly is black of color finally
an interesting question the answer is
yes and no functionally it's a color if
we mix all the primary colors together
we get something that very much
resembles black but on the other hand
technically blackness is the absence of
light which is a chromatic then heck I
kept typing things that started is bull
until eventually I typed is Benj and
after the question of whether Natalie
Portman's fiance is Jewish you come to
is Benjamin Button real hold on Hank I
have to make a quick journey over to my
desk then we have is Benjamin Franklin a
president a question that with its
present tense an indefinite article
implies either that we have more than
one president of the United States or
that Benjamin Franklin may be a member
of the presidents of the United States
of America sadly neither is the case
Benjamin Franklin was never the
President of the United States and he
certainly isn't now in fact it is my sad
duty to inform the Googlers of the world
that Benjamin Franklin American Hero
Patriot non president has died yes Hank
the good always leave us too soon
Benjamin Franklin was a mere 84 years
old when he died 221 years ago so anyway
Hank I kept playing around then
eventually I googled is B book is B Berg
a German for basketball in jail by a
girl really 51 dead or going to North
Korea also is Bieber fever calm free
Hank you'll be surprised to learn that
the answer to all these questions is
either no or aah so Hank welcome to 2011
year when Google believed we wanted to
know whether a pop star was a deceased
imprisoned 51 year old gay bisexual
female German basketball on its way to
North Korea Hank I think it's safe to
say that we did not imagine that world
on January 1st 2007 nerdfighters thanks
for sticking with us all this time we're
going to continue Monday Wednesday
Friday videos in 2011 but we have heard
you that you want more question videos
more thoughts from places and more info
tation Alvira are here to grant your
wishes as long as your wishes aren't
weird to that end I will be doing a
question Tuesday video with this Friday
so please leave questions and comments I
will answer as many of them as I can in
four minutes hank dftba I will see you
on Friday
Wednesday right why do you think my
mental calender is suddenly going to
improve after four years oh and by the
way still nothing